things have gotten so bad and debased  with the 2022 Republican party that when  they simply concede an election they  lose they're praised as being Noble uh  this happened with Doug mastriano now  listen I understand why Doug mastriano  was a January 6th attendee who would  clearly try to steal Pennsylvania for  Trump in 2024 if he had become governor  and Trump were the nominee uh and Doug  mastriano conceded and I sort of get the  surprise because mastriano is horrible  and he started talking about fraud and  all sorts of stuff  I get why we were like oh wow he  actually conceded but think about how  low the standards have gotten that just  conceding is something we would praise  you lost move on that's it but this  Republican party is so depraved that we  actually go oh well how good of them to  concede